et direction la tunisie où les soutiens
du parti ennahdha compte bien manifester
aujourd'hui malgré l'annulation des
célébrations de l'anniversaire de la
révolution du jasmin en raison de la
pandémie face à la flambée des nouveaux
cas de coronavirus le gouvernement à
adopter de nouvelles mesures sanitaires
notamment le couvre-feu ou encore
l'interdiction de se rassembler les
précisions à tunis de ben hassen chébili
de nouvelles mesures restrictives ont
été annoncées par le gouvernement pour
faire face à la hausse inquiétante des
cas de contamination aux variants
omicron en tunisie des mesures qui sont
entrées en vigueur ce jeudi parmi
lesquels un couvre feu de 22h à 5h du
matin le report ou l'annulation de tout
événement public ou encore le
durcissement du contrôle des passes
sanitaire une annonce qui tombe à point
nommé pour le gouvernement alors que de
nombreux partis politiques et
associations civiles ont appelé à
manifester le 14 janvier date
anniversaire de la révolution de 2011
pour exprimer leur rejet du processus du
25 juillet et lutter contre ce qu'il
qualifie je cite de dictature émergente
à la tête de l'opposition le parti
ennahda qui n'a jamais cessé de dénoncer
un coup d'état constitutionnel a annoncé
que son rassemblement du 14 janvier aura
bien lieu malgré les interdictions la
formation politique a invité ses
partisans et toutes les forces
nationales à venir massivement à une
marche de la détermination en opposition
à ce qu'elle considère comme des
violations flagrantes des libertés
écouter la célébration de l'anniversaire
de la révolution du 14 janvier aura lieu
malgré l'interdiction des rassemblements
dans les espaces ouverts énoncées dans
un communiqué de la présidence du
gouvernement cette manifestation
s'inscrit dans le cadre de protestation
contre les décisions présidentielles du
25 juillet le coup d'état et la crise
socio économique qui s'est exacerbée au
cours des six derniers mois même son de
cloche du côté des démocrates tunisiens
qui ont annoncé être au rendez vous de
cet anniversaire que le chef de l'état
souhaite bannir de la mémoire écoutez
nous serons au rendez vous le 14 janvier
sur l'avenue de la révolution pour la
commémoration de la révolution du 14
janvier et ce quelle que soit la
décision que prendra le gouvernement
dans le sens de l'interdiction des
rassemblements
la date du 14 janvier est emblématique
et kaïs sayyed
à rayer de la mémoire des tunisiens d'un
trait partis de l'opposition et société
civile sont bien déterminées a commémoré
vendredi le 11ème anniversaire de la
révolution de 2011 malgré l'interdiction
de tous les rassemblements pendant
quinze jours avec un message clair
adressé au chef de l'état celui du
retour à la démocratie et de la fin des
mesures d'exception